i've heard many stories of people
reusing masks
it has been over a year since lindsay
allison lost her father-in-law
john to covid and she's been wanting
answers ever since
john was 76 and his family say he caught
the virus in a care home
shortly after being discharged from
hospital he died
two weeks later a year ago roughly to
the day
mingyu was satya nick talking about how
the health secretary said that his
main aim was to protect shield the
elderly and the vulnerable
and i think what he meant by that was
the nhs because care homes didn't get
protected
as we know is still denying it and
it's just not on we've not had any
apology he refuses to admit any fault
whatsoever
at the beginning of the pandemic many
care homes struggled to prevent the
spread of covid
this was either because ppe supplies
were scarce or because thousands of
hospital patients
were sent to care homes without a test
but matt hancock told the committee
that untested discharges contributed to
just one point six percent of care home
deaths
instead claiming staff might have
brought the virus in
from the community sadly the biggest
route of covert 19 into care homes is
through the community
it's through people who live in the
community and work in the in the care
home
that's angered people like pearl jackson
who runs 21 care homes across england
and has been in the care business for
nearly 40 years
19 residents in this home died of covid
we were out there swimming or paddling
on our own
so it's rather offensive to suggest
otherwise
what you've heard the health secretary
say and how he explains events
how far removed is it from the way you
witnessed events it's the opposite what
happened
and i can understand he's trying to
explain his position
it's a very difficult position as health
minister julia a pandemic
but it's not what happened the health
secretary says the government tried to
protect
care homes from the very start but matt
hancock's account
of the government's early handling of
the crisis in care homes
is now widely disputed by many of those
who witnessed it first hand
nick martin sky news